[Música]
con cantos y lo que llamaron lágrimas de
sangre así protestaron cientos de
ciudadanos de mianmar en la ciudad de
rangún
estamos estudiando haciendo nuestro
trabajo pero algunos tratan a los
manifestantes como criminales no
deberían tratarnos así deberían tratar
hacia las fuerzas de seguridad que son
los que realmente están creando
problemas para nuestra gente
decenas de personas quemaron copias de
la constitución de 2008 redactada por
los militares las caravanas también
inundaron la ciudad de dawei piden el
fin de la represión la renuncia de la
junta militar y el retorno de la
democracia
se cumplen dos meses del golpe de estado
del primero de febrero en los que más de
530 civiles han sido asesinados por el
ejército según la ong asociación de
asistencia para prisioneros políticos
este jueves los abogados de la derrocada
líder aún san suu kyi de 75 años
revelaron que hace una semana un
tribunal acusó a ella a cuatro
colaboradores de su gobierno de violar
la ley de secretos oficiales una
normativa de la era colonial se trata
del cargo más serio en su contra hasta
el momento y podría acarrearle una pena
de 14 años de prisión su abogada aseguró
que se encuentra en buen estado de salud
allí incluso un vestido azul y una
mascarilla se veía animada fue bueno
verla se ve saludable no puedo decir si
está al tanto de lo que está ocurriendo
en el país debido a la circunstancia
el depuesto gobierno democrático pidió
una intervención militar extranjera un
día después de que la enviada especial
de naciones unidas a mianmar alertará
sobre el riesgo de una guerra civil tras
los recientes enfrentamientos del
ejército birmano con el ejército de la
independencia kachin uno de los grupos
étnicos armados más poderosos del país